hi I'm Matt Welch with nick gillespie
we're here on ask a libertarian 2012 day
in honor of the paperback publication of
the Declaration of Independence how
libertarian politics can't fix what's
wrong with America our next question
comes via conversation with reason
economics columnist and known French
person Veronique de Rugy do we have more
to fear from an unrestrained majority
enforcing its preferences via laws or
from narrow special interests furthering
their agenda by capturing government
excellent question Nick I you know I one
of the great things about being a
libertarian as you can choose you don't
have to make a single choice and I think
the real question there is you know how
do you combat these two twin threats you
know either people just say okay we want
it this way and trying to make that the
law of the land or narrow special
interests getting what they want out of
a government I think we have to combat
two and one thing over the past year
since the original release of
declaration one of the things I become
more of a fan of is actually in
convincing people that there are certain
principles of governance that should be
widely shared disseminated discussed and
enforce them one of them is that
majority rights don't Trump all minority
rights there's always a question of
where that that line gets drawn but it
should be drawn more in favor of the
individual rights than group rights for
sure and then in terms of crony
capitalism whatnot this goes back to our
question about the libertarian moment
we're talking about this stuff in a way
that we weren't a few years ago that's
clearly a prelude to something maybe not
to change that we want but the change we
want isn't going to happen without these
conversations I'm not one of those
people who talks a lot about the genius
of the Constitution however the genius
of the Constitution is that it does
enforce minority rights or it looks out
for the rights of the minority whenever
a government gets too big for its
britches probably not as much as as some
of us would like to see it being
restrained but that's the constant
tension that we have and thankfully
there is this check that is used at
least some of the time to keep the
majority from
rush roughshod over the minority we're
here for ask a libertarian keep those
questions coming and we'll see you again
real soon